please tell me about the part about
tatooine
okay i'm actually from tatooine the sun
planet in star wars
so that's that's a cool way to introduce
yourself in the u.s like everybody knows
about that wind it's uh actually my city
tattoo in in tunisia in north africa
which is the last city before the desert
and where indeed like george lucas and
star wars crew filmed like multiple
episodes and yeah like actually instead
it started there
[Music]
easter deep has reached the point where
it's expanding into the united states
and you have opened an office right here
in the cic but that's why we're here
today um to kind of welcome instadeep
and karim and the whole company to the
community here and we thought it would
be fun to have a discussion i know that
instadeep is working on
a range of problems
then they include
railway scheduling
virus early warning systems for
different viral variants of coping 19 i
assume and other viruses immunotherapy
research
shipping container packing circuit board
routing and protein design
and what's the common computational
thread that links all those things the
common thread between all of these is uh
artificial intelligence but even like
more narrowly what we call decision
making ai which is really about like
helping like industrial leaders in
different fields from biotech to
logistics and others make
decisions in complex space
using super computers and do it very
very quickly so that's sort of like the
unifying technology we're passionate
about ai passionate not only about the
research side we very like open source
we do a lot of public research but also
about the applications in multiple
fields with our partners anybody who's
seen that wonderful documentary about
alphago
kind of has an understanding of how they
taught alphago to be so good at go you
can teach the computer the complete set
of rules to go but there is no complete
set of rules about how to optimally load
a cargo container ship or how to route
all the trains in germany so that they
are exactly on time and at maximum
capacity all the time how how do
problems from industry how can you even
address them
when you don't know the rules alpha zero
in its original formulation uh is a
a two-player like zero-sum game so it's
really like somebody wins somebody loses
and the system effectively plays against
itself and as a consequence uh starts to
learn you know from what works and what
doesn't and my insight at the time which
led to our first actual research paper
is the fact that it plays against itself
so it could do completely crazy random
things but
one will lead to a good outcome and one
will lead to a bad outcome and so if you
improve the probability of what works
and reduce the probability of what
doesn't conceptually you can make
progress the idea we had that in study
by the time was
we're gonna actually create a system
where the algorithm proposes suggestions
and we're going to compare it versus
like their other suggestions uh think
about it like you know you're a very bad
tennis player for example okay
let me tell you how ai will look at it
then so essentially like it doesn't
matter if you're getting like like a
perfect serve or something provided
you're doing it slightly better than
what you are doing so it's the notion of
relative rewards and relative ranking
rather than absolute
that was on paper ranked rewards that
she which she published it was our first
paper at instead
and and remarkably because you know we
were very inspired by our colleagues at
at google and deepmind
david silver himself
uh met with us and read the paper
and he said wow this is amazing
we
essentially
landed
in the world of
like top ai researchers with real
credibility we were a young startup
mainly based in africa with you know uh
like versioning teams in in paris and
london but still small teams and this
convinced me that
the approach we had at instead about
like doing the deep tech innovation
between the developing world and the
developer world
could actually
be productive
and different from what has been done
before and we've just accelerated since
then
that's the point where a lot of startups
probably would open an office in
palo alto or mountain view right or san
francisco or maybe cambridge um
you didn't you kept growing in africa
and also in paris and london i realized
that you know
like the us is a leader in ai it's a
very competitive market it's like winner
takes all type of market it's also a
market where it's relatively difficult
to acquire top talent because your
direct competition is basically are the
tech giants
very well funded startups we didn't have
like significant funding yet
and at the same time it was very clear
to me that we could really grow and
continue to grow organically or teams
in africa with my background in france
it was relatively easy to get known and
meet top talents in france same thing in
the uk so that was the notion and really
like waiting for the company to get to a
level of maturity
and visibility that would make an
expansion in the us
worthwhile is not just to come to the
u.s is to come to us to have a huge
impact to do things that others others
have not done insadep aims to become a
leading decision-making ai company it is
already a leader in europe middle east
and africa and the goal now is to expand
to the u.s and ultimately build a global
company we love to partner with experts
in their field whether it's
like deutsche ban who's a leader in
railway management systems or biontech
who's a leader in biotechnology and
you know the way insta deep operates is
we're very collaborative
and hopefully in future and in
particular in the us we will collaborate
with leaders in their field from whether
it's like food delivery or
airlines or like shipping industry
cambridge and uh like the ecosystem here
from mit to harvard
is uh is world-class and when it comes
to research and we're quite excited
about that we're looking forward just to
build
like really productive research
collaborations
and by having a presence here
developing our partnerships also with
the tech giants uh were partners with
google we partners with nvidia when we
started everybody said you guys are
crazy it will never work do you think
you can do like
high-grade ai research and development
you're fooling yourself well we like we
proved uh the naysayers wrong
and as a consequence indeed i've seen
many young founders of startups in
africa coming to say
thank you because you've shown that this
is possible you've shown that you can
build a globally competitive company
with a bridge between the developing
world and the developed world it's an
exciting moment welcome to cambridge
thank you and may the force be with you
[Music]